vraiment finie et médias libres comme ça
les d'y aller gagner petit bout comme ça
j'espère qu'elle ne va pas à dire dans
la flotte a fait des volailles elle va
elle va prendre la bouée tout juste
juste tout juste voilà tout juste à la
rive à l'abri la butte à côté d'elle
elle va couper la ligne d'arrivée ça
c'est l'une des deux bouts de la ligne
la ligne d'arrivée ccfm étant je pense
que la ligne est coupée à 12h13
12h56 exactement victoire d'étape plus
la pologne
il fait un champion qui a donc remporté
cette longue étape en tranquillité c'est
bien le départ et du groupe devait
écouter leurs qualités à 9h aller aux
ali pour la proposition d autres lieux
en attendant l'ambiance sur la ligne
d'arrivée avec kelly gbagbo alors que
nous sommes à la numéro
calé babeau la bière sous la ligne
d'arrivée la victoire vient encore
chercher
la perte des faits aujourd'hui en tout
cas sa victoire pour cette étape je
voulais
l'ambiance
et on revient avec les yoles retour sur
la ligne d'arrivée
là
ma silva
quelle ambiance du côté de samedi avec
la victoire du fr champions les autres
viols avec aller aux ali camille a
dressé ce qu'à dieu ça sera super dur
mais ça sera aussi un joli à voir
rentrer j'appelais les appétits
l'appaloosa digicel petit navire et j'ai
un fax au trail pour qui la deuxième
place un peu de patience et que l'auteur
arrive comme ça se tient ça peut
compliquer le vent donc
il n'y a pratiquement plus de vent tant
que le cahier bas et fascine mais on a
vu effectivement dans le code contre
elle viré le digicel attention va virer
également et et regarder ce qui va se
passer entre 13 et j'ai appelé ça fait
tilt appaloosa weppes a pensé à tout et
voilà que passeur bail
voilà c'est fait pour un contre lg pas
caraïbes et jableh appétit l'appaloosa
on peut vous dire qu'il doit pas les 10
2 minutes et ça c'est sûr
les vols à l'evo ali al-abdallah les
axes de félix mérine le patron du fn
champions et fn champion qui a gagné
cette 5e étape en possibilités ses
bières
alors qu'elle est gbagbo sous la ligne
d'arrivée
alors proche de félix mérine peu avant
son interview
allo
pas évidente à siros
sanaa mardi the brink nous oblige à
garder tous les jours mon jardin grâce à
des attaques et des mauvais jours et
ouais ça va et ludo rendra impossible -
si vous louez
chaque jour
trois talents mais nous sommes un état
nation russe 10e trou
c'est mon palmarès tout patron lui il
casse à moins que certains disent oh non
mais ça fait trop petit c'est très fort
au faible coût et bon j aimerais batibo
minutes entre 5,6 et bamako sous dix
neuf boeing un peu plus à l'est au bond
la moitié du volet c'est là qu'on s'est
baladé nadia morel abus
voilà un être seul félix mérine
maintenant plus de quatre minutes kiev
un chauffeur de la ville de robert va
remporter cette étape à les rosalies
avec les autres viols qui se battent
pour les accessits aller aux ali et le
reste avec vous jean trudeau en
attendant à l'evo ali la chute pour la
deuxième la troisième place la deuxième
et la troisième place et surtout là le
temps a compté pour le décompte a fait
un pool le classement le temps
classement général parce que laguiole
qui est arrivé la première ufr
changement avait 21 minutes de retard au
classement général sur la yole qui va
certainement arriver en deuxième
position gm les appétits la panoz a donc
il va voir on va falloir en ciel s'est
rapproché si là le vent est en train de
tomber donc laguiole familiale avant -
vie tu veux faire changer de la chance
d'arriver dans le vent il va falloir
jouer entretiens conduits décompte des
temps on savoir la position exacte de
laguiole gère les appétits la panoz n 7
et demi par rapport au classement
général un docteur pour les accessits la
belle bagarre entre lui et les yoles
suivante à savoir quel gf1 du robert
digicel du françois
et puis ensuite habitude marc gaillard
zapetti gerblé l'appaloosa avance le
leader du tout aller rosalie la position
de leader du tour we came y est nous
sommes lampe est à noter quand même que
cette bagarre pour la deuxième place et
bien avantage à jablé ça fait tilt
appaloosa mais ça se rend compte peu
compliqué parce que les hommes en deux
vagues avant très donc sur cette ligne
d'arrivée d'eau qu'elles sont obligées
de tirs et 9 rebonds pour pouvoir se
positionner essayer de franchir cette
ligne d'arrivée digicel semble peut-être
bien passé j'ai appelé ça pète il
appaloosa attiré à bord donc offrir une
nouvelle fois pour essayer de se
replacer faut essayer de franchir cette
ligne d'arrivée en deuxième position
mais diable est resté sous la menace tôt
que deux mutuelles magallanes
menace également parvenus à ses parts
cotrel gf1 messiah les appétits
l'appaloosa qui repart gerbe les
appétits l'appaloosa qui repart et qui a
pourrait bien surprendre cette deuxième
place et le chrono qui a me semble t'il
affiche déjà plus de six minutes 6
minutes est à peu près 30 secondes pour
depuis donc le passage tu es faire un
champion dont c'est apporter bâti fin je
checke pas mal précisé
on aura donc les votants tout à l'heure
aux dread on crée des officielles et
auprès d'économistes rur de la
fédération dont côté yolande mais juste
pour vous donner une idée dont code
l'écart attention pour la 12ème place
pour agir blé les appétits l'appaloosa
qui devrait donc eu la franchise donc
avec moins de huit minutes de retard
donc un ce serait à peu près donc un
retard rythme là son sillon donc avec
moins de dix minutes torretta donc que
ce serait à peu près donc à 38,1 pour
appeler ça fait tilt à tadoussac suivi
donc un jet à côté en scène de péter
velappan